هل القمح الضروره فعلا ام ادمان وما علاقه
المؤامرات السياسيه به
ولماذا لم يعد بمقدورنا الاستغناء عنه
الغذائيه
من بدايه العام ارتفاع في اسعار
الرعب من وقوع المجاعه كلما طرا التحذيرات
عن ازمه قمح عالميه
هذه المخاوف ليست مجرد زوبعه في فنجان بل
تستند الى الظروف التي سبقت اقصى المجاعات
في التاريخ
وجميعها ارتبطت بفقدان القمح في اوروبا
مات سبعه ملايين شخص بين عامي
و1,317 بسبب نقص القمح
ولسبب نفسه مات نحو 30 مليون انسان في
الصين عام
1961 في واحده من اكبر مجاعات العصر
الحديث ليس هذا وحسب بل للقمح دور رئيس في
احداث غير المجرى التاريخ فقد كان شراره
اشتعال الثوره الفرنسيه وعنه يقول الجنرال
لا تبحث عن اسباب الحرب في براميل البارود
بل في صوانع القمح
لطالما ارتبطت حبه القمح بحجمها الصغير
بتطور الحياه المدنيه وتحضر البشريه على
الارض ثم تختلاف على تاريخ زراعه البشر
للقمح والراجح ان منشا حبه القمح كان في
وادي دجله والفرات سنه
2700 قبل الميلاد ومن ارض العراق انتقلت
الى فلسطين ومصر وعلى ضفاف النيل نضجت
انواع فريده من القمح ونجح المصريون في
طحنها وعجنها ثم ابتكروا الافران وظهر
الخبز
وتحولت الحبه الصفراء بذلك من سلعه زراعيه
عاديه الى اهم غذاء في تاريخ البشريه على
الاطلاق
[موسيقى]
خبز القمح يوفر اليوم نصف حاجه سكان الارض
من السعرات الحراريه لاحتوائه على عنصر
الكربوهيدرات بنسبه 80% وما بين تسعه الى
15% من البروتين الى جانب فيتامين باء
وعناصر البوتاسيوم والحديد والكالسيوم هذه
الاغذيه تحتاجها اجسامنا للبقاء على قيد
الحياه ولو قرر الانسان الحصول عليها
بعيدا عن القمح لا احتاج الى مجموعه
مختلفه من اللحوم والنباتات تبلغ تكلفتها
اضعاف سعر رغيف الخبز العادي
ومع كل هذه المقدمات ما يزال بعض العلماء
يفترض وجود اسباب اخرى لاقبالنا الشديد
على القمح ويحاول العثور على تفسيرات
حاسمه حول ذلك في ستينيات القرن الماضي
طور مهندسون من دول مختلفه اصنافا جديده
من البذور من اجل زياده كميه القمح الذي
يمكن حصاده في كل فدان ونتج عن هذا ظهور
نوع القمح القزم المعروف بكونه اقل فائده
غذائيه وتنسب له الكثير من المشكلات
الصحيه حسب ما تقول الباحثه في علوم
الغذاء كيتي لكن بعد هذا التاريخ تضاعف
اعتماد البشر على القمح وظهرت ما تعرف
باستراتيجيه القمح التي تبنتها دول غربيه
ومنها الولايات المتحده رابع منتج للحبوب
في العالم تجاه عدد من دول الشرق الاوسط
وافريقيا وساهم ذلك جعل القمح سلاح نفوذ
وهيمله واداه دبلوماسيه ناجعه
تقوم هذه الاستراتيجيه على توفير القمح
الاوروبي والامريكي للدول المستورده باقل
بكثير من تكلفه زراعته وانتاجه محليا
ويزعم ان الولايات المتحده تمنع دولا عده
من زراعه القمح وتهددها بعقوبات اقتصاديه
ولم تسلم من هذه الاستراتيجيه حتى الدول
التي لم تكن تعتمد القمح غذاء اساسيا
وكانت تنشط في زراعه الذره والدخن مثل
السودان
ففي عام
1974 بدات واشنطن بتغيير ذوق السودانيين
حسب وصف الكاتب سعيد ابو كمبال من خلال
بيع الخرطوم القمح بقرود ميسره جدا توقفت
هذه القروض عام
1991 بعد ان دار السودانيون ظهرهم للذره
والدخن الاكثر جوده وفائده صحيه واعتلى
القمح قائمه السلع الزراعيه الاكثر طلبا
في السودان
تنفي الولايات المتحده منع دول من زراعه
القمح لكن هذه المزاعم يدعمها كتاب ضد
الحبوب الذي الفه استاذ الدراسات الزراعيه
في جامعه ييل جيمس
ويرى فيه ان توجها عالميا طرا بهدف تركيز
اهتمام البشر على القمح لاسباب
الايديولوجيه واقتصاديه واستبداديه ويذهب
الى ابعد من ذلك بالقول ان زراعه القمح
يكون مسؤوله عن تغيير بنيتنا الجسديه
وادمغتنا لجعلنا اكثر قابليه للانقياد
والانفصال عن الطبيعه اثبات هذه الفرضيات
يحتاج تحقيقات مطوله لكن المؤكد علميا ان
القمح الابيض الذي نتناوله اليوم قد يكون
سببا للاصابه ببعض الامراض المزمنه في
جهاز الهضم وعلى راسها السكري من الدرجه
الثانيه علما ان هذه المخاطر لا تاتي من
كل انواع الحبوب بل تتراوح بين نوع واخر
ومع هذه المخاطر المتداوله اصبحت الدعوات
الى الامتناع عن تناول القمح ومشتقاته من
الحملات الرائجه بقوه في مجتمعاتنا
الافتراضيه
[موسيقى]
منصات الكترونيه وشاشات تلفزيونيه باتت
تخصص ساعات لاخصائي تغذيه ليستعرضوا فوائد
ترك الخبز نهائيا على الصحه الجسديه
والنفسيه يصر الاخصائيون على ان علاقتنا
بالقمح والخبز هي ادمان يحتاج لبرامج
توعيه مثل التدخين والسكر وليست عاده
غذائيه يسهل الاقلاع عنها لكن ما دام
الانسان قادرا على الحياه بلا قمح مثل ما
يقول الاخصائيون فلماذا لم تتبدد مخاوف
صندوق الغذاء العالمي من عوده المجاعات في
كثير من البلدان